Thanks Kyle. Let's use the day object to do another calculation. If you haven't
already booted up BlueJ, you should do it now and open up the days project.
Mariner4 launched November 28, 1964. It took 228 days to arrive on Mars. What
was its arrival date? Before you do this, I want to show you one more thing
that you can do with objects. I've opened up the days project in BlueJ. I can
make a day object and now I can quickly see exactly the day that's in here
using the two string method. I won't actually do it, because I want you to be
able to do this yourself. And try it. But that should make it much quicker. So
here are some hints. Use a day object to do the calculation And use the
toString method to read the day. Make sure that when you write the arrival
date, you use the same format that the toString method uses. And don't worry
too much if you don't have BlueJ working yet. You can just skip to the answer
video and watch it carefully. There will be more examples you can do soon.